uh these clouds are we're just seeing
the beginning of them it's just the
beginning of the season of some high
clouds over the next few days as we head
towards a really busy holiday weekend
we've got beautiful skies out there
looking out over the spring mountains we
do expect to see increasing southwest
winds along with a few more of those
high clouds through the day as well
it feels a little better out there this
morning still cool we've got kind of
some 40s on the fringe neighborhoods in
the fringe neighborhoods of the around
the valley but 50s inside the valley
yesterday morning we were down in the
40s even nellis was in the 30s yesterday
morning
right now red rocks in the 30s we're not
feeling too much in the way of winds the
spring mountains have a few breezes but
not much 30 degrees in caliani 37 indian
springs 45 in front
reno's looking for some rain and snow
from the system that's moving into
california we're not going to get that
but we're all going to get some of that
wind near 50 right now in boulder city
and mid 50s in laughlin and those winds
are going to be out of the southwest and
that's going to help push our
temperatures right back to normal
yesterday at 69 today we're looking for
78 with a mix of high clouds and
sunshine that sunrise was 609 sunset at
7 14. we're not looking for record highs
in the eight day forecast but we are
looking for a warm-up as we head into
next week and easter weekend will be a
little warmer too but still there is a
quite a bit of snow kind of spread out
across the great basin the intermountain
west here's the next system it's right
on the coast of northern california
northern california will welcome the
rain and snow they need as much as they
can get as well we just won't get any of
it but that low will work against our
high pressure and that's what's going to
help increase those southwest breezes
today to about 25 miles an hour so
breezy through the afternoon and tonight
unfortunately the wind is not good over
new mexico boy they've been fighting
this big fire it's called the mcbride
fire it's grown to more than five
thousand acres two people have died in
this fire now it's in rio doso new
mexico that's between albuquerque and el
paso texas
it has just been bone dry winds were up
near 90 miles an hour yesterday they've
got red flag warnings again today as
firefighters try to fight this fire
they've got 150 structures that have
either been damaged or they've been
destroyed as they've been trying to
fight this fire so it is critical
situation there so breezy to windy today
into tonight
temperatures increase to the low 80s
with a little bit lighter wind on friday
passover begins tomorrow evening it's
good friday tomorrow there's a lot going
on and then this weekend more winds come
in on saturday these could be rougher
winds we might even have wind advisories
for saturday we're going to watch that
and then a warm easter sunday yeah
easter bunnies hopping around with mid
80s and those temps hop right up to 90
degrees on monday with upper 80s next
week